les galaxies que vous voyez ici ne
devrait pas exister
et pourtant le télescope spatial James
web les a bel et bien observés et
photographiés c'est toute la cosmologie
qui est en crise si l'on en croit
certains ces galaxies impossibles
impliqueraient même que la théorie du
Big Bang serait fausse le Big Bang
n'aurait jamais eu lieu alors comment
dire non ok c'est vrai le télescope
James web semble avoir détecté des
galaxies qu'on n'attendait pas qui sont
à la fois très lointaines et assez
massive et on ne pensait pas que c'était
possible de là à remettre en question le
Big Bang comme on l'a lu ou entendu
parfois il y a encore du chemin
aujourd'hui on va donc essayer de
comprendre ce qu'a vraiment observé ce
télescope pourquoi c'est surprenant à
quel point c'est solide et en quoi cela
pourrait modifier notre compréhension
actuelle de l'histoire de l'Univers
[Musique]
puisque c'est ça dont on va parler
commençons par rappeler brièvement ce
qu'est le Big Bang il s'agit d'un modèle
de l'histoire de l'univers qui nous dit
qu'il y a environ 13,8 milliards
d'années ce dernier était dans un état
incroyablement dense et chaud et qu'il
sait depuis étendu et refroidit donne en
essence aux atomes aux étoiles aux
galaxies derrière cette idée il y a un
modèle mathématique précis qui découle
des équations de la relativité générale
et qui nous permet de reconstituer
précisément l'évolution de l'Univers
pendant ces 13,8 milliards d'années et
surtout on dispose aujourd'hui de
nombreuses observations astrophysiques
qui viennent corroborer le modèle du Big
Bang en nous renseignant sur l'état de
l'univers à différentes époques on peut
mentionner la nucléosynthèse primordiale
le rayonnement fossile qu'on sait
caractérisé avec une précision
incroyable l'expansion de l'Univers
elle-même qu'on peut mesurer précisément
grâce à la loi de Hubble ou encore la
répartition des galaxies et la structure
à grande échelle de l'univers
scientifiquement parlant le modèle du
Big Bang est donc très solide et aucun
chercheur du domaine ne le remet en
cause de façon significative pourtant il
est vrai que tout n'est pas encore
limpide et que ce modèle fait intervenir
quelques ingrédients dont la nature
n'est pas élucidé comme la matière noire
ou l'inflation j'ai consacré pas mal de
vidéos à ces différents éléments et je
vous y renvoie pour avoir plus de
détails après ces petits rappels sur le
modèle du Big Bang voyons maintenant ce
Coret observé le télescope James web et
qui remettrait en cause ce modèle pour
ceux qui l'auraient raté ce télescope a
été lancé par Ariane 5 en décembre 2021
et a fourni ses premières images à l'été
2022 il est le successeur du télescope
spatial Hubble mais il est évidemment
beaucoup plus puissant ce qui lui permet
de voir des objets encore plus lointains
mais en astronomie quand on parle de
voir des objets très lointains il se
passe un truc un peu contre-intuitif on
sait que la lumière ne se déplace pas de
façon instantanée elle a une certaine
vitesse 300 000 km par seconde environ
et donc quand un rayon lumineux atteint
le télescope disons en ce moment ce
rayon a en fait été émis par sa source
il y a un certain temps le temps qu'il a
fallu à la lumière pour faire le voyage
un temps d'autant plus long que l'objet
qu'on observe est lointain
par exemple ces deux galaxies qu'on
appelle les galaxies du papillon on les
voit tel qu'elles étaient il y a environ
65 millions d'années mais on ne sait pas
à quoi elle ressemble aujourd'hui
inversement s'il y a des astronomes
extraterrestres dans ces galaxies avec
des télescopes incroyablement puissants
et bien rassurez-vous il ne peuvent pas
nous voir nous les humains actuellement
ils sont en train de voir la terre telle
qu'elle était il y a 65 millions
d'années à peu près au moment de
l'extinction des dinosaures et on peut
pousser le bouchon beaucoup plus loin si
la lumière d'une galaxie lointaine a mis
13 milliards d'années à nous parvenir et
bien on va voir cette galaxie telle
qu'elle était il y a 13 milliards
d'années quand l'univers avait à peine
800 millions d'années avec un télescope
voire très loin ça permet de remonter
dans le passé de l'univers et donc de
comprendre comment il était à ses
époques lointaines mais comment fait-on
pour savoir qu'un objet astrophysique
qu'on observe se trouve effectivement
loin qu'est-ce qui nous permet d'estimer
sa distance et donc de savoir de combien
on remonte dans le passé en l'observant
et bien on utilise le phénomène du
décalage vers le rouge on sait que du
fait de l'expansion de l'Univers plus la
lumière aura voyagé dans l'espace avant
de nous parvenir plus à longueur d'onde
sera allongée et quand la longueur
d'onde s'allonge cela la décale vers le
rouge voir l'infrarouge donc plus un
objet est distant plus il nous
apparaîtra décalé vers le rouge alors ça
a l'air bien comme idée mais il y a
quand même une ambiguïté imaginons que
j'observe une galaxie et que je vois
qu'elle est effectivement assez rouge
comment je vous fais pour savoir si
c'est une galaxie qui est lointaine et a
donc subi un décalage important ou bien
si c'est simplement une galaxie plus
proche mais qui est naturellement rouge
parce qu'elle contient beaucoup
d'étoiles rouges par exemple
bah oui on sait que la couleur des
étoiles peut varier notamment en
fonction de leur température qui dépend
de leur taille de leur âge certaines
étoiles sont plus rouges que d'autres
alors comment on fait la distinction
entre une galaxie proche et rouge et une
galaxie lointaine est décalée vers le
rouge et bien on utilise des spectres
lumineux c'est à dire des courbes qui
représentent la quantité de lumière
reçue par le télescope en fonction des
différentes longueurs d'onde or ces
spectre ont des formes assez
particulières qu'on sait interpréter
voici par exemple le genre de spectre
que l'on peut observer ce qu'on voit ici
c'est le flux lumineux mesuré en
fonction de la longueur d'onde de la
lumière exprimée en nanomètre et on voit
qu'il y a des pics et des creux assez
marqués ces pics et ses creux sont dus
au raid d'absorption et d'émissions des
différents éléments qu'on trouve dans
les galaxies
prenons l'hydrogène l'élément le plus
abondant dans l'univers on sait qu'il
absorbe et émet de la lumière à des
longueurs d'onde bien particulières qui
sont liées aux transitions entre les
niveaux d'énergie de l'atome d'hydrogène
et cela va créer des pics et des creux
dans les spectres par exemple sur ce
spectre le pic vers 480 nanomètres
correspond à ce qu'on appelle l'arrêt
Liman alpha de l'hydrogène qui provient
de la transition entre le niveau 2 et le
niveau 1 d'énergie
en principe quand on la mesure sur terre
c'est très à une longueur d'onde
d'environ 120 nanomètres or là on voit
sur le spectre qu'elle est à 480 à cause
du décalage vers le rouge d'ailleurs
quand on parle de décalage vers le rouge
il faut savoir qu'il agit sur les
longueurs d'ondes comme un facteur
multiplicatif ici il y a un facteur
d'environ 4 qui fait passer de 120 à 480
et d'ailleurs on retrouve ce même
facteur sur d'autres caractéristiques du
spectre la raie Liman alpha est ici très
visible mais on sait identifier les
autres et le relier à différentes raies
de l'hydrogène ou d'autres éléments sur
ce spectre si on regarde dans le détail
on peut mesurer que toutes les longueurs
d'ondes sont multipliées par environ 4
pour quantifier le décalage vers le
rouge de façon universelle on utilise un
nombre qu'on appelle en anglais red
shift et on le note généralement Z pour
ça on prend le facteur multiplicatif
qu'on a trouvé et on enlève un
sur l'exemple que je vous ai donné il y
avait un facteur 4 donc ça correspond à
un redshift d'environ Z = 3 pas de
décalage du tout c'est Z = 0 et plus Z
augmente plus le décalage est important
et donc plus l'objet qu'on observe est
éloigné ce qui veut dire que la lumière
que l'on reçoit a été mise il y a
d'autant plus longtemps voilà pourquoi
chaque fois qu'on observe un objet
astrophysique lointain on donne toujours
en général son red shift son Z ça nous
renseigne à la fois sur le décalage de
longueur d'onde sur sa distance mais
aussi sur son âge car grâce à ce conseil
de l'expansion l'univers on peut relier
la valeur du raidshift à l'âge de
l'univers au moment où la lumière a été
émise voici la courbe qui donne le lien
entre les deux
la courbe commence à 13,8 milliards
d'années pour Z = 0 c'est logique si
vous mesurez un raid shift de 0 pas de
décalage c'est que la lumière a été
émise de très récemment donc à un moment
où l'univers avait son âge actuel c'est
à dire 13,8 milliards d'années et plus
le red shift est élevé plus l'univers
était jeune au moment de l'émission de
la lumière pour le spectre qu'on a tracé
tout à l'heure on avait estimé à être
shift de 3 et on voit que ça correspond
à un univers d'environ 2 milliards
d'années seulement et pour des red
shifts au-delà de 6 l'univers avait
moins d'un milliard d'années au moment
où la lumière a été émise
mais ce qu'on estimait les
astrophysiciens c'est que cette galaxie
était à ce moment-là relativement petite
probablement 100 fois moins massive que
la nôtre et c'est assez cohérent on
parle d'une galaxie encore très jeune on
ne s'attend pas à ce qu'elle soit déjà
très grosse mais récemment le télescope
James web avec sa puissance inégalée a
pu faire des découvertes plutôt
surprenantes
[Musique]
ce qui a découvert le télescope James
web ce sont des galaxies avec un ratif
relativement élevé entre 7 et 9 mais qui
sont étonnamment massives vous voyez ici
les images de ces galaxies avec cette
fois les données associées le redshift
et la masse alors premier point puisque
les red shift sont très élevés les
longueurs d'ondes qu'on observe sont
très décalées dans l'infrarouge ces
photos sont donc en fausse couleur sinon
vous verrez rien
ensuite des red shift de cet ordre là
entre cette et 9 ça veut dire qu'on voit
ces galaxies telles qu'elles étaient
environ 700 millions d'années après le
Big Bang donc très tôt dans l'histoire
de l'Univers
enfin les masses estimées sont données
ici en milliards de masse solaire on
utilise la masse du Soleil comme unité
et on le figure avec ce petit symbole un
point dans un cercle par comparaison la
Voie lactée est actuellement autour de
50 à 100 milliards donc vous voyez qu'on
est sur des galaxies qui sont presque
aussi grosses que la nôtre et ça on
s'attendait pas à ce que ça soit
possible
pour comprendre ce résultat et voir en
quoi il est perturbant il faut que je
précise une chose on parle ici de la
masse stellaire de la galaxie
c'est-à-dire la masse des étoiles
qu'elle contient de façon générale si on
considère la masse totale d'une galaxie
on sait qu'environ seulement 1/5 est de
la matière ordinaire on parle de matière
baryonique tout le reste c'est de la
matière noire
ensuite sur cette matière baryonique
seule une fraction est sous forme
d'étoiles qui brille dont on peut
observer la lumière c'est la masse
stellaire tout le reste est
essentiellement sous forme de gaz
dispersé entre les étoiles surtout de
l'hydrogène et l'hélium
et donc sur ces images quand on estime
la masse d'une galaxie on parle
seulement de la masse stellaire qu'on
exprime donc en milliard de masse
solaire alors pourquoi ces galaxies nous
surprennent-elles et bien parce que leur
masse stellaire est trop élevé par
rapport à ce à quoi on s'attendrait pour
des galaxies si jeunes je vous évoqué
plutôt qu'une des confirmations
expérimentales du modèle du Big Bang
vient de la structure à grande échelle
de l'univers on sait en effet simuler la
formation et l'évolution des galaxies et
la comparer à ce qu'on observe
actuellement dans l'univers j'y avais
consacré une vidéo d'ailleurs ça
fonctionne très bien et c'est
simulations permettent notamment de
savoir à quel rythme se forme les
galaxies ainsi que les étoiles à
l'intérieur on peut donc estimer à
quelle quantité de galaxies on est censé
s'attendre à chaque étape de l'histoire
de l'Univers et quelle taille peuvent
avoir ces galaxies
et c'est ce qui permet de dire que la
découverte de ces galaxies qui sont à la
fois jeunes et pleines d'étoiles et
plutôt improbable pour ceux qui aiment
les détails on sait estimer l’abondance
des halo de matière noire et donc des
galaxies possibles en fonction de leur
taille et durée de shift plus on remonte
dans le temps vers des redshifts élevés
plus les grosses galaxies sont
improbables
et c'est ce qui nous permet de dire que
c'est quelques galaxies observées par le
télescope James web ne semble pas trop
coller elles sont trop grosses pour leur
âge elles ne sont pas impossibles mais
elles devraient être rares or on en a vu
plusieurs donc on a un problème ou ce
que les astrophysiciens aiment bien
appeler une tension je vous avais déjà
parlé de la tension sur la valeur de la
constante de Hubble et bien là c'est
pareil la théorie et les observations ne
collent pas trop et il va falloir
comprendre et essayer de résoudre
l'attention alors maintenant voyons
ensemble les pistes
[Musique]
quand on a ce genre de situation la
première chose à faire avant
d'échafauder des théories nouvelles
c'est de s'assurer que les mesures sont
solides et là c'est pas encore
complètement le cas bon déjà on s'est
rendu compte que le télescope James web
marchait beaucoup mieux que prévu et il
a donc fallu refaire les calibrations ce
qui a amené à modérer un peu les
résultats sur cette figure on voit en
rouge les redshift et les masters
estimés des galaxies telles qu'elles ont
été publiées dans l'article final dans
la revue Nature en février 2023 et ça
c'est le même diagramme dont la première
version la publication sur le Web
seulement en juillet 2022 on voit très
nettement qu'ils ont dû revoir à la
baisse leurs ambitions du fait de la
recalibration donc déjà l'énorme tension
annoncée initialement n'est plus si
grosse que ça
ensuite je vous ai expliqué tout à
l'heure comment on pouvait estimer le
redshift d'une galaxie à partir des
spectres lumineux qui couvrent toute une
gamme de longueur d'onde sauf que là en
fait les spectres on les a pas comme je
le racontais dans ma vidéo sur le James
web ce télescope est équipé de plusieurs
instruments certains comme nearspeck
permettent effectivement de faire de la
spectroscopie c'est-à-dire de mesurer
des spectres lumineux complets mais on
les utilise en général sur un objet
précis quand on sait déjà ce qu'on
cherche là c'est galaxie étrange ont été
détectés avec un instrument plus général
qui s'appelle nirkam et qui sert à
observer de plus grandes portions du
ciel pour détecter de nouveaux objets
si je vous raconte tout ça c'est pour
vous montrer que quand on annonce une
valeur de red shift mesurée sans faire
de spectre d'une part ça demande pas mal
de calcul pour y arriver et d'autre part
il y a des incertitudes
bon et pour les masters annoncés est-ce
qu'il y a aussi des incertitudes parce
que c'est quand même ça le résultat
marquant de l'article des galaxies qui
ont l'air particulièrement massives et
bien oui là aussi la méthode est subtile
et il y a des incertitudes alors comment
on fait pour estimer la masse stellaire
d'une galaxie bon déjà on peut mesurer
sa luminosité apparente et si on connaît
sa distance ce que nous donne le red
shift on peut en déduire ça luminosité
intrinsèque intuitivement plus la
luminosité intrinsèque est élevée plus
il y a d’étoiles donc plus la masse
stellaire est importante facile non et
ben non car malheureusement la masse
d'une galaxie n'est pas strictement
proportionnelle à sa luminosité voyons
comment ça fonctionne imaginez que je
mesure la luminosité intrinsèque d'une
galaxie et que je trouve qu'elle
correspond à 1000 fois la luminosité
solaire alors mille fois c'est beaucoup
trop petit pour une vraie galaxie mais
c'est pour l'exemple
une hypothèse naturelle serait de dire
qu'elle contient environ 1000 étoiles
comme le soleil le soleil qui par
définition a une masse de une masse
solaire et une luminosité de une
luminosité solaire
donc ma galaxie aurait une masse de 1000
masses solaires facile mais ça c'est si
toutes les étoiles qui composent ma
galaxie sont comme le soleil mais
supposé cool lieu de ça elle soit
composée de grosses étoiles bleues comme
l'étoile Spica une étoile bleue peut à
elle seule à avoir 1000 fois la
luminosité du soleil tout en ayant que 5
fois ça masse avec cette hypothèse on
aurait qu'une seule étoile dans la
galaxie pour expliquer cette luminosité
et donc une masse estimée de seulement
cinq masses solaires soit 200 fois plus
faible que l'hypothèse précédente
à l'inverse les étoiles qu'on appelle
les naines rouges peuvent avoir une
luminosité 100 fois plus faible que le
soleil tout en faisant 0,2 masse solaire
pour expliquer la luminosité totale de
ma Galaxy avec des naines rouges il en
faudrait 100 000 ce qui représenterait
une masse totale de 20 000 masses
solaires
voyez donc que pour une luminosité
donnée de la galaxie ici 1000 luminosité
solaire la masse stellaire
correspondante peut facilement varier
entre 5 et 20 000 suivant les hypothèses
que l'on prend sur les étoiles qui
composent la galaxie et donc déduire la
masse stellaire d'une galaxie juste à
partir de sa luminosité intrinsèque mais
en fait c'est compliqué alors
heureusement on a des moyens d'estimer
la quantité d'étoiles de chaque type
qu'on peut trouver dans une galaxie on
procède dans deux temps d'abord pour une
galaxie nouvelle qui vient de se former
on s'attend à une certaine distribution
des masses des nouvelles étoiles ça
s'appelle la fonction de masse initiale
ensuite on a besoin de connaître l'âge
de la galaxie pour savoir comment cette
répartition aura évolué et je dis bien
l'âge de la galaxie pas le temps qui
s'est écoulé depuis le Big Bang
heureusement on peut estimer cet âge
grâce à une autre spécificité du spectre
qu'on appelle le break de Balmer c'est
ce petit saut qu'on voit ici et dont la
taille nous renseigne sur l'abondance
des différentes étoiles petite moyenne
grosse sauf que je vous rappelle ici
qu'on ne mesure pas vraiment ce saut on
le devine en ayant essayé de coller des
spectres à nos 7 points de mesure et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a tant
d'incertitudes sur les masters des
galaxies bref ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que quand on estime les masses de
ces galaxies on doit vraiment faire pas
mal d'hypothèses et de calcul pour
essayer de tirer une valeur à partir des
quelques points de mesure dont on
dispose et pour être certain et bien il
nous faudrait les spectres complets
alors rassurez-vous un maintenant qu'on
a détecté ces galaxies il y aura des
campagnes d'observation dédiées ou le
télescope James web pourra aller
spécifiquement pointer ces quelques
galaxies candidates et en faire un
spectre afin de confirmer ou infirmer ce
qui a été détecté jusqu'ici
si les mesures sont confirmées et
résistent aux explications alternatives
ça signifie effectivement qu'il y a une
tension un truc qu'on n'arrive pas à
expliquer avec nos modèles actuels de
l'évolution de l'univers et de la
formation des galaxies peut-être qu'il
faudra repenser certains aspects des
modèles comme la distribution de masse
initialisées étoiles ou peut-être qu'il
faudra envisager des changements plus
importants comme on essaye déjà de le
faire pour résoudre la tension sur la
constante de Bubble dans tous les cas il
va falloir être patient et attendre des
mesures plus précises pour savoir si oui
ou non c'est galaxie sont si bizarres
que ça merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo
comme toujours abonnez-vous si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas rejoignez le serveur
discord de science étonnante pour
prolonger la discussion le lien est en
description et puis moi je vous dis à
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo à
bientôt
[Musique]